Вулиці в Німеччині знову стануть малолюдними, як навесні 2020 року.
З 2 листопада в країні на 4 тижні запроваджують обмеження для громадян і бізнесу.
Щоправда, ухвалені заходи є м'якшими, ніж у березні, тому їх називають "м'яким локдауном".
Контакти повинні бути зведені до "абсолютного мінімуму".
Зустрічатися дозволено - як під одним дахом, так і на відкритому повітрі -
групами не більше десяти осіб і максимум з двох домогосподарств.
Кафе й ресторани працюватимуть лише на виніс,
а кінотеатри, тренажерні зали, басейни, сауни, парки розваг, а також театри будуть зачинені.
Не працюватимуть також косметичні студії і масажні салони. Дозволена лише робота перукарень.
Відчиненими залишаються магазини, не лише продовольчі, а й роздрібної торгівлі.
Однак вони мусять обмежити кількість покупців, які одночасно перебувають у приміщеннях
- з розрахунку одна людина на десять квадратних метрів.
Не збираються зачиняти наразі і школи й дитячі садки, натомість їм доведеться посилити правила гігієни.
Богослужінь локдаун теж не торкнеться.
Ночувати в готелях з туристичною метою не дозволять.
Уряд закликав німців, як і раніше, утриматися від "необов'язкових" приватних подорожей.
Футбольні матчі проходитимуть за порожніх трибун, хоча стадіони лише восени
дозволили заповнювати до 1/5 їхніх потужностей.
Обмеження поки запроваджуються на чотири тижні.
Але якщо за перші два тижні статистика епідемії не піде на спад, локдаун доведеться продовжити,
застерегли німецькі урядовці.
Досі німецький уряд декларував бажання уникнути другої зупинки соціального та економічного життя в країні.
Однак загострення епідемії змусило до небажаних дій.
За даними Інституту імені Роберта Коха, станом на 29 жовтня за минулу добу
зафіксовано понад 16 тисяч нових випадків інфікування.
Активних випадків - більше 135 тисяч. Це удвічі більше, ніж на піку першої хвилі пандемії у квітні.
Заходи, які діяли раніше, не приносять результатів.
Як підкреслила Анґела Меркель, потрібні нові кроки, аби "переламати інфекційну хвилю".
Ми маємо діяти, діяти зараз. Діяти, аби уникнути надзвичайної ситуації в сфері охорони здоров'я нашої країни.
М'який локдаун підтримують провідні вірусологи та епідеміологи країни.
Зокрема, Крістіан Дростен, який користується довірою канцлерки Німеччини й регулярно консультує уряд.
На думку більшості науковців, міні-локдауни повинні тривати щонайменше два тижні.
Дростен вважає ще більш ефективними три тижні, аби захистити систему охорони здоров'я від колапсу.
Наразі у відділеннях інтенсивної терапії Німеччини заповнено три чверті ліжкомісць і є невеликий резерв.
Але важких пацієнтів з COVID-19 стає дедалі більше, тож медики бояться, що не впораються і станеться медична катастрофа.
Противників обмежень цього разу значно більше, ніж під час першого локдауну. Це і бізнес, і політики, і окремі вірусологи.
Так, лунає аргумент, що підприємства гастрономії не були осередками інфекції,
коли там дотримувались стандартів гігієни. На відміну від приватних святкувань.
Також кажуть про загрозу зникнення робочих місць та банкрутства підприємств галузі.
Щоправда, уряд ФРН поспішив заспокоїти підприємців, пообіцявши компенсувати їм 70-75 відсотків
недоотриманих прибутків, відштовхуючись від показників жовтня. Для цього уряд готовий виділити до 10 мільярдів євро.
Проти нового локдауну - частина політиків, особливо на сході країни.
Правопопулістська "Альтернатива для Німеччини" й ліберальна Вільна демократична партія називають заходи протиправними,
Ліві сумніваються в ефективності заходів.
Водночас дедалі більше пересічних німців, навпаки, підтримують жорсткіші обмежувальні заходи.
Так, за даними опитування Politbarometer телекомпанії ZDF, проведеного 20-22 жовтня,
лише абсолютна меншість - 14 відсотків – вважають чинні правила надмірними.
Натомість кількість людей, які хотіли б суворіших заходів для приборкання епідемії,
зросла від вересня до кінця жовтня з 18 до 30 відсотків.
Хоча обмеження в цей час і так вже почали посилювати.
Наприклад, обмежили нічне життя та заборонили збиратися великими групами.
Дотримання правил тепер нерідко контролює поліція. Є навіть грошові штрафи.
Тож, судячи з усього, скептики нині все-таки у меншості.
Рішення про локдаун Анґела Меркель узгоджувала з керівниками 16 федеральних земель.
Адже, аби запровадити ці заходи, кожна земля ще має видати відповідні розпорядження.
Цього вимагає федеративний устрій Німеччини.
Під час наради найбільш рішучим прибічником обмежень, поряд з центральним урядом, був очільник Баварії.
Водночас у деяких федеральних землях, зокрема східнонімецькій Тюрингії,
висловлювався скепсис щодо доцільності тих чи інших заходів.
Втім, врешті нараді вдалося узгодити однакові заходи по всій Німеччині.